TO GET MORE ON THIS, WE WANT TO
GO TO DEEZ NUTS 2016 CAMPAIGN
HEADQUARTERS IN IOWA TO CHECK IN
WITH THE CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Mike: THANKS, LARRY!
>> Larry: MIKE YARD?
YOU'RE THE DEEZ NUTS CAMPAIGN
MANAGER?
>> Mike: YUP!
WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THIS STORY
LAST NIGHT, I QUIT THE SHOW AND
FLEW OUT TO IOWA.
LARRY, SOMETIMES YOU JUST GOTTA
FOLLOW YOUR HEART, MAN.
AND IN THIS CASE, I GOTTA FOLLOW
DEEZ NUTS!
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: WAIT, SO YOU'RE
WILLING TO THROW AWAY A CAREER
IN TELEVISION TO GO WORK ON A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN?
BECAUSE IT HAS A FUNNY NAME?
>> Mike: HELL, YEAH.
I'M EXCITED, LARRY!
THIS IS A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY.
IF YOU LISTEN TO MY CANDIDATE'S
STANCE ON ENTITLEMENT REFORM,
HE...
I'M JUST KIDDING -- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DEEZ NUTS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
WHAT MORE DO YOU WANT FROM A
PERSON RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN
2016?
>> Larry: IDEAS FOR HOW TO
MAKE AMERICA BETTER?
>> Mike: YOU SOUND LIKE MARTIN
O'MALLEY.
THAT DUDE'S POLLING AT 2%.
YOU KNOW WHY, LARRY?
NAME NON-RECOGNITION.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT ANYTHING HE
HAS TO SAY BECAUSE HIS NAME IS
BORING.
WAKE ME UP WHEN YOU WANNA TALK
ABOUT DEEZ NUTS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Ricky: LARRY, LARRY.
>> Larry: OH, YES.
LET'S GO TO RICKY VELEZ, WHO'S
COVERING THE SOCIAL MEDIA ANGLE
FROM "THE NIGHTLY SHOW" DATA
CENTER.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
HEY, RICKY!
>> Ricky: I'M HERE FOLLOWING
THIS PHENOMENON, AND YOU SHOULD
SEE THESE, LARRY.
>> Larry: OH, THESE WHAT?
>> Ricky: DEEZ NUTS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT, FINE.
I GET IT.
>> Ricky: THIS IS REALLY
CATCHING ON, LARRY.
IT LOOKS LIKE EVERYONE'S PULLING
FOR...
DEEZ NUTS.
>> Larry: OKAY, I THINK YOU'RE
JUST HAVING FUN SAYING THIS.
>> Ricky: NO, I'M NOT, LARRY.
YOU KNOW I TAKE MY WORK VERY
SERIOUSLY.
LET ME READ YOU THIS.
THIS REPORT SAYS DEEZ NUTS ARE
BLOWING UP ON TWITTER, DEEZ NUTS
ARE SHOWING UP ON INSTAGRAM, AND
DEEZ NUTS ARE SPREADING ALL OVER
YOUR FACE...
Facebook PAGE, LARRY!
>> Larry: OH, UH...
(LAUGHTER)
ALL YOU'RE DOING IS MAKING A
JOKE OUT OF DEEZ NUTS.
>> Ricky: DEEZ WHAT?
>> Larry: DEEZ NUTS!
NOW YOU GOT ME SAYING IT!
YOU GOT ME.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Holly: LARRY, CAN I
INTERJECT HERE?
>> Larry: OH, YES, THANK YOU.
HOLLY WALKER, EVERYBODY, COMING
TO US FROM THE COUNCIL FOR
WOMEN'S VOTING.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
GO AHEAD, HOLLY.
>> Holly: LARRY, THIS IS THE
MOST JUVENILE THING I'VE EVER
SEEN.
>> Larry: THANK YOU, YES!
I AGREE!
>> Holly: ONCE AGAIN, ALL OUR
POLITICAL DISCOURSE IS DOMINATED
BY MALES AND THEIR LOCKER ROOM
SENSIBILITIES.
WE'RE NOT HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT ISSUES THAT MATTER.
>> Larry: EXACTLY, HOLLY,
THAT'S MY POINT.
THANK YOU.
>> Holly: UB WELCOME.
>> Larry: SO WHO'S THE
CANDIDATE YOU'RE MOST INTERESTED
IN TALKING ABOUT?
>> Holly: LARRY, THERE IS A
VERY EXCITING DARK HORSE OUT OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
SHE'S A FEMALE CANDIDATE WHO HAS
A LOT TO SAY.
>> Larry: GREAT, WHAT'S HER
NAME?
>> DEEZ TITTIES!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: OKAY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS, HOLLY.
NOW YOU'RE DOING IT, TOO?
>> Holly: NO, LARRY.
I'M COMPLETELY SERIOUS.
DEEZ TITTIES SPRANG OUTTA
NOWHERE.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: REALLY.
>> Holly: YES, LARRY.
THE CAMPAIGN WAS SAGGING, BUT
NOW THEY'RE STARTING TO PICK UP,
AND THEY'RE GETTING A LOT OF
SUPPORT.
HER POLL NUMBERS ARE LIFTING AND
SEPARATING THROUGH THE SWING
STATES.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: THAT DOESN'T EVEN
MAKE SENSE!
MIKE YARD, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
THERE?
I THOUGHT YOU WERE WORKING WITH
DEEZ NUTS.
>> Mike: I WAS UNTIL I HEARD
ABOUT DEEZ TITTIES.
>> Holly: DEEZ NUTS!
>> Ricky: LARRY, I'M GETTING
INFORMATION THAT DEEZ NUTS AND
DEEZ TITTIES ARE JOINING FORCES.
>> Larry: I KNOW.
I'VE HEARD.
OKAY.
I'VE HAD ENOUGH OF THIS.
MIC, HOLLY AND RICKY, EVERYBODY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.